Alice: 没有
Alice: No.
Jake:那你删
Jake: Then you delete it.
Jake: 你是多少啊
Jake: What's your number?
Tasha: 哎呀我已经叉掉了
Tasha: Oh, I've already crossed it out.
Jake: 没关系没问题
Jake: It's okay, no problem.
Jake: 再再来了
Jake: Let's do it again.
Jake: 硕
Jake: Shure.
Shure: 哎哎哎
Shure: Hey, hey, hey.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Katrina:  你那个甜品展架啥的买了吗
Katrina: Did you buy the dessert stand?
Jake: 啊这个可以
Jake: Oh, this is fine.
Tasha: 哎他这个居然没有停止他的进度哎
Tasha: Wow, it actually didn't stop its progress.
Jake: OK可以
Jake: OK, it's fine.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Alright.
Jake: 呃我们先收拾收拾去吧
Jake: Uh, let's tidy up first.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Okay?
Shure: 一想到搬所有，所有的塑料袋
Shure: Thinking about moving all the plastic bags...
Shure: 然后在里面洗澡
Shure: ...and then showering in them.
Shure: 好，好羞耻
Shure: It's so embarrassing.
Katrina:  害怕不
Katrina: Are you scared?
Jake: 为啥
Jake: Why?
Tasha: 还好你没洗碗
Tasha: Good thing you didn't wash the dishes.
Jake: 那那你你先画我们先上去
Jake: Then you, you draw first, we'll go upstairs.
Jake: 走我们上去收拾收拾
Jake: Let's go upstairs and tidy up.
Tasha: 你要在楼上洗碗吗
Tasha: Are you going to wash dishes upstairs?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Tasha: 是在楼上洗碗吗
Tasha: Is it upstairs where you wash dishes?
Jake: 是啊
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  我要洗碗
Shure: I'll wash dishes.
Shure:  了吧
Shure: Okay?
Jake: 洗了吗
Jake: Did you wash them?
Tasha: 带这个厨房湿巾就行了
Tasha: Just bring these kitchen wipes.
Jake:不要
Jake: No.
Jake: 出来领眼镜
Jake: 随时不着急
Jake: Anytime, no rush.
Jake: 我们先把这个收拾收拾
Jake: Let's tidy this up first.
Jake: 然后再把呃房间每人秀一下
Jake: Then each of us show the room.
Jake: yes好的
Jake: Yes, okay.
Jake:好
Jake: Good.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 我去
Jake: Oh my.
Jake: 无从下手
Jake: I have no idea where to start.
Jake: 还挺暖和的
Jake: It's pretty warm.
Jake:索性穿了起来
Jake: I just decided to put it on.
Alice: 直接倒进去吗
Alice: Should I just pour it in?
Alice: 我靠你这手
Alice: Wow, look at your hand.
Jake: 嗯我去我这手
Jake: Yeah, wow, look at my hand.
Alice:嗯来
Alice: Okay, here.
Alice: 直接倒进去
Alice: Just pour it in.
Alice:不会把下水下水道给堵了吗
Alice: Won't it clog the drain?
Tasha: 他不是有网吗
Tasha: Doesn't it have a strainer?
Tasha: 我在当时想
Tasha: That's what I was thinking.
Alice:就这个油一凝固他不就
Alice: But if the oil solidifies...
Tasha: 所以尽快让他溶下去吗
Tasha: So, let it dissolve quickly?
Tasha: 没关系我们后面不用这个池子
Tasha: It's okay, we won't use this sink later.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:乾坤
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Jake: 得得这样是吧
Jake: So, like this, right?
Jake: 这样有用吗
Jake: Will this even work?
Alice: 没关系随便吧
Alice: It's fine, whatever.
Tasha: 有用
Tasha: It works.
Alice: 好玩吗
Alice: Is this fun?
Jake:我也不想玩
Jake: I don't want to play.
Jake: 说实话
Jake: Honestly.
Tasha: 我们要打扫干净才能离开这个民宿
Tasha: We need to clean up before we leave this Airbnb.
Tasha: 对吗
Tasha: Right?
Jake:是吧
Jake: Yeah, right?
Jake: 我现在擦也没啥用
Jake: Cleaning now is pointless.
Tasha: 擦呀
Tasha: Just clean it.
Alice: 要不用这个先洗洗这个吧
Alice: Or should we wash this first?
Tasha: 这这这里面不是有
Tasha: Isn't there detergent here?
Tasha: 洗洁精吗
Tasha: We've got dish soap, right?
Alice: 这个油比较多嘛
Alice: There's a lot of grease though.
Jake:先先先先洗这个是吧
Jake: So, wash this first, right?
Jake: 先洗哪个呀
Jake: Which one should I wash first?
Tasha: 那你就先洗锅吧
Tasha: Then just wash the pot first.
Jake: 好那这个我我扔
Jake: Okay, then I'll throw this...
Jake: 我扔哪了
Jake: Where should I throw this?
Tasha: 哪个
Tasha: Which one?
Jake:里面的东西
Jake: The stuff inside
Alice: 这个垃圾桶呢
Alice: What about this trash can
Jake: 给个袋子吧
Jake: Give me a bag
Jake: 来来袋子袋子上袋子
Jake: Come on, a bag, a bag, get a bag
Alice: 是不是在那啥
Alice: Is it over there?
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh dear
Alice:用这个吧
Alice: Use this one
Tasha: 上才艺
Tasha: Show some talent
Jake: 这有啥才艺
Jake: What talent is there?
Tasha: 倒
Tasha: Pour it
Tasha: 还好我觉得今天浪费的一点都不多
Tasha: Luckily, I think we didn't waste much today
Jake:都拍下来了
Jake: It's all recorded
Jake: 哎呀不好意思
Jake: Oh, I'm sorry
Tasha: 这不是不好意思就可以的
Tasha: Sorry isn't enough
Jake: 对不起对不起对不起
Jake: I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry
Tasha: 啊哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice:私密马赛
Alice: Sorry (in Japanese)
Jake: 我先放地上吧
Jake: I'll put it on the floor first
Jake: 可以吗
Jake: Is that okay?
Tasha: 放呀
Tasha: Go ahead
Jake: 我也没有别的地方放
Jake: I don't have anywhere else to put it
Jake: 或者放那边桌上
Jake: Or put it on that table
Jake: 放到桌上
Jake: 喔这个竟然
Jake: Oh, this actually...
Jake:你们竟然有火烤
Jake: You guys actually have a grill
Alice: 难道我要别在我的腰上
Alice: Should I hang it on my waist?